- Moving very quickly on.
The eagle-eyed amongst you all
notice that we have
two chairs next to me.
One of these chairs
is for Kerry Flynn
who is a journalist who's
written for Huffington Post,
Forbes, Money Magazine,
and is now business reporter
for Mashable with a particular
specialism in the tech industry.
The other chair is
for Gary Vaynerchuk
who has a formidable
headline which is
Gary Vaynerchuk
Builds Businesses.
And that is something that
absolutely no one can argue.
Straight out of college he
took his family business
from three million to
60 million in five years.
He's a prolific angel
investor and venture capitalist
with investments including
Uber, Facebook, and BirchBox.
He now runs VaynerMedia,
social media
first digital agency
and has been named to
both Fortune and Craine's
40 under 40 lists this year.
Please welcome Carrie and Gary.
(applause)
- Hello.
- Hey, guys.
Thank you for that
great introduction.
Yes, I'm Kerry Flynn,
I write for Mashable.
I'm here with Gary.
You got a brief introduction,
I'm thinking you guys
probably all know of
Gary Vaynerchuk,
but I would love, Gary,
for you to just
introduce yourself.
When you go to an event,
how do you introduce yourself?
- Well, I think the
fragmentation of attention
and marketing and
coms is so intriguing.
How many people here
have no idea who I am?
Raise your hand.
Oh, that was better.
That was a good ego boost.
(laughter)
Usually how I go in to
conferences is ask that question
and the number is
always very, very high,
and I can always see
the organizers squirming
of either they overpaid me
or they feel bad for me.
(laughter)
But usually, I contextualize
myself as an entrepreneur.
But I always reverse
engineer the audience.
My biggest want up here in
our next 30 minutes is...
I was walking around and
looking at name tags,
asked ahead of time, we talked.
To me, what I'm gonna
deliver is the context
of what I think is the
most interesting and most
valuable thing to talk about
to the people in the room.
I think as somebody who's
been on stage a lot,
I'm fascinated by how
80% of presentations
are just one long press release.
I think I take
this very seriously,
and the way I introduce myself
usually is under the context
of what could
conceivably bring value
to the people in the audience.
- Great.
Well, then let's talk a
little bit about VaynerMedia
in terms of building that
out because it seems to be
you really went with
that mission in mind.
What did you really
want to offer the world
that didn't exist before?
- I grew up in my family's
liquor store business
and I launched one of the first
e-commerce wine
businesses in 1996.
And I built my
business with no money,
and the reason it became
a big business was because
I bought Google Adwords
the day it came out
for five cents a
click for the word wine,
and because
I started a YouTube show
five months after
YouTube came out,
and because I had an
email newsletter in 1997
that had 91% open rates.
(laughter)
So, my entire narrative
has been very simple.
And I think for all
of us in this room,
I think the
world is pretty basic,
mainly because I'm pretty
basic, which is there's
overpriced attention and
there's under-priced attention.
And while most of the
world spends a lot of time
trying to quantify
and find the R.O.I.
of under-priced attention,
I think the better model
is to be a practitioner
on your intuition around
normal people's behavior,
learn it,
and maximize the R.O.I.
So, I did that for my family
business, that went great.
Then I invested in
all these companies:
Facebook, Twitter, Tumblr,
made a lot of money,
and then I decided, in my
continued mission to buy
the New York Jets,
though they're testing me,
(laughter)
that the way I was
gonna do that was
to buy brands and flip them.
So, I think nostalgia
is the most under-priced
asset in the world, and
so my dream is to buy
Tootsie Rolls, or K-Swiss
sneakers, or what have you,
at scale, 50, 60, 100,
200 million dollars,
do the thing that I do,
and then flip it
for one billion dollars.
And that's how I think I,
from a self-aware standpoint,
can achieve my audacious goal.
To do that, I knew that
I needed to understand
marketing and media at the
scale of which I wasn't
playing at as an entrepreneur
and as an investor.
So, I decided seven years
ago to eat shit for a decade
and build a client
service business.
(laughter)
(chuckles)
And I needed to learn why
all these big brands were
doing the things that
I thought were stupid
because I didn't have
the audacity or the ego
to think they were stupid,
I just knew they were
playing a different game.
I had to understand why.
I'm a bad student,
I learn by doing,
and so I set out to build
the best marketing machine,
is what I would call
it more than an agency.
We've grown very fast.
First two years I was still
busy with the wine business
and I had a book
that went very viral
that kind of dragged
me out there.
But for the last five
years I've run the business
we've gone from
30 to 750 people,
from three to
100 million in revenue,
all organic, no M-and-A.
So, we've built
a real big business,
and I think we've
done it because
our interests have been
aligned with our clients
because I'm not trying
to build an agency
to sell to Martin Sorrell,
I'm trying to build
an agency for myself
to become my clients,
which has allowed us to be
very aligned with our clients,
which is very different
than the marketplace
of media agencies
and marketing agencies.
And we also do every capability
because I'm building
it for myself.
We do media buying,
and creative,
and analytics, and dev.
So, that's why it happened.
- Well, let's talk about
the early days then.
You said you looked around
and saw all these brands
doing quote, unquote,
stupid things.
- Yes.
- You don't have to
name names if you
don't want to.
- Television.
- But give me
some examples about
what were people doing wrong?
- To sit in this room in
October 2016 and have...
You know, it's funny.
Go out with one of your
friends that has nothing
to do with
marketing or business,
and explain the following:
okay, so here's how it works.
A human, a single human, at
an agency, a creative lead,
and another human
on the brand side.
And let me tell you about
the human on the brand side.
This person went to business
school to sell stuff
and run an operational P-and-L.
These two people sit,
the creative single person
humanly makes a
subjective call on a tagline
and a video concept,
narrows it down from the
seven or eight ideations
of his or her team
to one or two, because you only
have an hour to present it.
They go to the human that
is there to run a P-and-L.,
and the two of them make
a subjective creative call
of what that business should
stand for for the entire year,
and then that company takes
60 to 80% of it's monies
and makes a single 30
second video to be played
in a commercial format in 2016,
and this is to drive the
sales of their business.
There's no common
sensed human on Earth
that thinks that's a good idea.
(laughter)
We in the marketing
world play that game.
I think that's insanity,
that excites me,
that's the opportunity.
- Awesome.
(laughter)
- No, but really.
I don't know who does
what, and I could be wrong.
Let the market play itself out,
but who watches
a commercial in 2016?
So, here, and I want
to quantify this,
I'm not a digitalist
or a futurist,
I think the
Super Bowl commercial
is the number one
buy in marketing.
If I buy a brand tomorrow,
and I have a limited
amount of money,
the first thing
I buy is the Super Bowl
because everybody in America
is going to pay attention
to that whether they watch it
on YouTube or during the game,
and I have 30 seconds to
tell you what I'm about.
The problem with Super Bowl
ads is they're a showcase
for creative agencies
to get new clients
and acquire more talent.
They're not there to sell shit.
So, I think that's the
best buy in marketing.
I think the worst buy in
marketing in the world
is the second most expensive
commercial on television.
I don't know what that is,
whether it's the Oscar's,
or the A.F.C. championship
game, or the Emmy's.
I don't know what it
is, but it's the worst
because we don't
watch those commercials.
It goes to commercial
and we grab our phone
and we talk about that
dress, or that play,
or what just happened.
Our attention's not there.
My living is very simple.
In my bio where it says
I build businesses,
I don't know what paper of my
team sends around these days,
but on the website
it says comma,
"I day trade attention."
Attention is the only asset.
It's the only asset.
And there's
overpriced attention,
and there's
under-priced attention.
Direct mail is
overpriced attention.
It works.
Spend $100,000
in direct mail,
you will get things happen,
but when you know that
there's a Facebook-targeted
world out there that you could
do it better and cheaper,
that's a better idea.
That's just what I spend
my whole life doing.
What's overpriced, what's
under-priced, what's practical.
I try to put myself out
of business everyday.
If I started VaynerMedia today,
we would be an Alexa
voice message bot,
top level domain consultant,
video production
vertical phone shop.
(laughter)
(chuckles)
I don't know.
What are we talking about?
(laughter)
- Well I think that yeah,
we're, just hearing about
what you guys are, I mean,
you talked about television,
you talked about Facebook,
so it, that from,
you know, I would assume
that people in the room here
could say there
are certain agencies
that specialize in television,
there are certain agencies
that specialize in digital.
There are certain
agencies that yeah,
like you're saying, are specific
voice recognition
chat bots, you guys
do actually wanna
conquer it all.
- Yes, but when
I say conquer it all,
A, my first level of
responsibility
is to deliver for our clients,
'cause they're paying us.
So Vayner in
it's current form today,
what we wanna do for a living is
we wanna spend our clients money
in a way that sells
them the most stuff,
or whatever they're
trying to achieve,
and we are completely
agnostic to where that is.
I built my career on Twitter.
It's where I came out of,
for some of you
that know who I am.
I wasn't happy that Twitter
was losing attention in 2011,
but when I was making those
videos five years ago,
like, I'm worried about this,
like, I was worried about it.
I was at the top of the heap,
I was one of the 25 most
followed people
in the world on Twitter,
like life was good.
I wish Twitter stayed
for a thousand years,
it would have been easy,
I wasn't happy to put in work
on Vine, and Snapchat
and Instagram.
It's just, it's not my choice,
and what I'm fascinated by
is how many people are willing
to draw lines in the sand
and hold on to things
because they're in their
short-term financial
vested interest.
It is a massive business
vulnerability, and--
- So what do people
need to get rid of?
Like if you had to give
people a list of like,
three things maybe
that people should
stop doing in their
current agencies.
- Emotion, emotion's a
good thing to get rid of.
And I mean that.
I think that a lot
of things that are
holding people back
is the emotion of it,
they hold certain
things on a pedestal.
We hold, for example, let me,
let me give you a good example.
We think, somehow in
our current society,
we've decided that if you write
another human being a letter,
that you are somehow now
the greatest fucking
human being on Earth.
(laughing)
Like, we put things on
pedestals for no reason.
We are so scared of change,
that we put writing a letter
on a pedestal, 'cause this
somehow means
you care so much, versus a text,
which at the end of the day
are exactly the same thing
if you write the
same thing, it's,
the message is the same,
it's the medium of delivery.
So I think the first thing
that people need to do
is actually get rid of emotion.
Number two, is have a real
conversation about measurement.
Yeah.
(laughing)
Like, measurement is--
You know, one of the great
things that happened to me
is I started an agency knowing
nothing about the business.
And I mean nothing.
I knew nothing, it was
actually quite stupid.
But you know,
what I did know was
my life as an immigrant,
that had a family
and liquor store business,
are KPI was not winning
an award in France, or getting
a headline in a magazine,
or some bullshit modeling mix
that was manipulated
to force the company
to spend money on
what they believe in.
Like, our KPI was selling
Pinot Grigio, right?
And so having that
DNA has helped me.
The amount of times I've
walked into a meeting
where the
Millard Brown case study,
the Data Logic study,
and the MMM have said
everything is phenomenal,
and the business is down 17%,
is way too often, and
somehow we accept that.
So, I think we have
to have a far more
serious conversation
around measurement,
because we're measuring
the wrong things.
This is, we are
absolutely somehow
eliminating common
sense from the equation.
And there was a lot,
I mean there's,
I just think it's
fundamentally fascinating.
I mean, I don't think
agencies are built
to have aligned interests
with their clients,
which is why you
get into weird tactics.
I think there's hidden
costs in production,
which is ludicrous,
I mean, I don't know.
I think the whole
thing is fasc--
I don't think it's,
but wait, who am I?
I'm one dude, I just think
that, I just think that
it's a very interesting
ecosystem.
Like, I went to a meeting where
the first presentation
was by a PR company
that claimed that some
mention in Huff Po
14 pages into
their website attributes
80 million impressions
for the month,
I mean like, we're just
playing weird games.
I think we're, we're just
eliminating common sense,
and I think that's
a huge mistake.
- Yeah, I think metrics is
a great thing to talk about
in terms of that, so
what, in terms of what
you're focused on when you
present to your clients,
I'm sure they still expect
you to present a report
of the traditional metrics.
- Oh, we do tons--
- So what do you show?
- of horseshit stuff.
We, we--
(laughing)
We do a ton of horse shit
stuff because we,
they force us to
after this conversation.
We say to them,
we want to measure sales,
you know, we wanna
measure the thing,
donations, like, the thing.
Like TV clients, Neilsen ratings
'cause that's your
currency you make money on.
Like, we wanna
measure the thing,
the problem is,
99% of our clients
do not put us in a position
to measure the thing.
Which gets me
into like, why doesn't
anybody wanna measure the thing?
(laughing)
Right?
Like, like I think nobody
wants to be held accountable.
I think one of the great
things about Corporate America
and agency landscape that
I didn't understand was,
I used to be mad at everybody.
Mad that you didn't care
enough to do the right thing.
Then what I realized is,
I can't be mad at you,
the game is structured in a way
that people are
playing within it,
because you have
mortgages, and a family,
and like, you're just,
you're making decisions
not on what you believe,
you're making decisions on
what is palpable and acceptable
within an ecosystem
that's created.
I get it, I'm more
empathetic to it.
Here's the punchline though,
if you're doing something
to grow within an organization,
or not rock the boat,
and have stability,
it doesn't mean what
you're doing is right.
It just means
it's right for you,
within the context of
the game that you chose.
In that human vulnerability
is enormous amounts
of business opportunity,
I plan to exploit that.
(laughing)
- So in terms of that, you
have these conversations,
but people just don't
wanna change, right?
So how do you make
people change?
You just keep doing you.
- You don't!
You don't.
I could care less
if anybody changes,
as a matter of fact,
I prefer that nobody changes.
Because when I get to
the second part of this,
it'll give me more
time to do my thing.
So I just want to be
historically correct,
and I want to
inspire some people
that just need a little tip
to go do the right thing,
and I wanna look
back at these videos
and be like, fuck,
you were smart.
And,
(laughing)
and I just want to just, like,
just, I mean, eventually--
See, what's interesting
for me is
there's a whole next
generation of people,
like, and this is gonna
create business opportunities.
I'm right, and everybody
knows it,
because you're right,
you know it!
I'm not a genius!
I'm just in a situation where
I'm allowed to talk about it
in a way that's different
than a lot of people.
Everybody knows,
you live your life one way,
and then you put on your
clothes that you wear to work,
your "Jersey" and you
act totally different
because you play within the
context of what's acceptable.
You don't believe in
the shit you're selling,
and I don't mean all of
you, like, a portion of you.
(laughing)
I just genuinely believe that,
you know why?
Because at three o'clock
in the morning at Cannes,
after a bottle of Rosé,
you all tell me.
(laughing)
So I don't know,
like, it's interesting.
And this happens
everywhere, like,
I yell at kids to not
to take VC money
'cause VC's are
giving you advice,
because they just
need one home run,
and they're gonna drive
all the rest of you
into the ground to
overextend your business
because for their business,
they just need one.
So like, I think you have to
understand the seed, right?
Like, most of the
agencies in this room
and in the market are
part of holding companies
that are publicly
traded companies,
which means that they
basically have to play
a 90 day, you know,
Wall Street dynamics,
which, that's what
maps their behavior.
There's no HR talk.
You know, like, but
for me there's HR talk,
I spend all my time on
HR, comma, I'm the CEO,
(laughing)
because I'm building something
for the rest of my life,
and I need these people.
So I have to care about them.
So again, it has
nothing to do with like,
anything other than, if you
understand the North Star,
and you can reverse engineer it,
that is where all
the true answers are.
- Well, then paint
me a picture of how
Vaynermdia looks, I mean,
you call yourself the CEO,
what is CEO mean at Vayner,
and who do you
surround yourself with?
That perhaps,
I'm sure as you know,
is different than the current,
maybe structure of other
companies here?
- No, I think we have a
lot of similar structures,
I think the only difference
is that Claude Silver,
my Chief Heart Officer
is the number two person
in the company, and that my
CFO, Scott has no say, right?
So like, we're not
financially driven, right?
We're not financially
driven, so that's probably
the only subtle difference.
We look like everybody else.
You know, I tried,
because I had blind,
you know, I had naive eyes,
I did a lot of different things,
but there's a lot
of tried and true
in the way you
should be structured.
I think the thing that,
the one thing
that my leads know,
is I don't want--
So nobody's
incentivized to grow business.
So one thing that's
weird about us is
a lot of people come from
all these great shops,
and they think they
need to grow the P-and-L
'cause they'll get a bonus,
and that's good for them,
so I've eliminated that
because I want our team
to play well in the sandbox
with other partners,
'cause that's the right
thing for the client.
And the only way
you can really do that
is if you create the
infrastructure for that.
Because if you incentivize
them around dollars,
they're gonna fight
for dollars, right?
So the only thing
they have to do
is be historically correct.
Like, to me, people are
gonna move brands,
this and that, like,
a lot more people
give us business today by
the things they thought
we were stupid
about three years ago,
and now they believe it, right?
People don't forget.
So I don't need
to win the scope,
I need to make sure that
everybody understands
where we stand
on how it plays out,
and what's in the best
interest to sell the product.
And so, those are the
things that are different,
but otherwise, I don't know,
we have a creative department,
we have account,
we have strategy, insights,
analytics, it's the
same horse shit.
(laughing)
- Well if you had to, you
know, add a new division,
or expand in a certain way,
what, what would you do next?
Unlimited resources.
- Well--
- What are you doing next?
- Well I think we're,
I think we do that,
I mean, I'm losing
all sorts of money
investing in you know,
message bot infrastructure,
we have VeynerSmart,
the smart-ification stuff.
Like, I'm, again,
building it for myself,
thus, I'm losing on my
P-and-L every day
with departments
that don't return,
because the clients
don't want it yet.
- To me I'm always
building for something
that's 12, 24 months
ahead of time.
I don't think you
should build anything
for five years out.
I think that lacks practicality.
I think, if you see
the world in a 12
or 18 month window,
and you can go there,
that feels real and
that's what I've
kind of, tried to
rinse and repeat.
So we do a lot of that.
You know, we invested
in Vertical Video people
two, three years ago,
'cause we saw that
playing out and
that's worked out for us.
Because the market has
moved more in that direction.
We, you know, we invested in
70,
you know, what I would
call new digital
paid media people who
probably believe more
in feed dynamics
of social networks
than programmatic banner
buying or, you know,
things of that nature,
and that's
working out for us.
So, I think, you know,
I'm, it's not even
unlimited budgets, what
I think I'm doing now,
which is, if I believe anything
is meaningful,
to sell something or
communicate something, we
will invest in it immediately.
We have, we have
analysts and strategists
who spend time on analyzing
Musical.ly a year ago,
you know, and so, that's
just kinda how we go.
- Awesome,
well increasing you guys
have offices in multiple places.
Do you wanna grow your
physical presence anytime soon?
- Yeah, so we have an
office in New York, LA,
San Francisco, Chattanooga
Tennessee, and London.
So I'll speak about Chattanooga,
Tennessee and London.
Chattanooga is one
of probably five
to seven more
offices that I will
build in cities
that are not New York,
LA, San Francisco, or Boston.
There's another part of America,
I don't know if you've heard.
And there's a lot of it, and so
I wanna have offices there.
Because if I buy a
brand that mainly sells
in middle America,
at Dollar General,
having a footprint
in these markets
for a decade is gonna be smart.
Same thing with London and Asia
and other places we will expand.
I'm only,
I'm very single minded.
I'm gonna buy brands
that are underpriced
because big holding
companies are not
supporting great brands because
they don't have
the money for it.
They're only supporting
the top five brands.
They're gonna
sell it to me for a
nickel on the dollar,
I'm gonna buy it,
I'm gonna refurbish
it in a 2022 world,
for whatever that is,
and I'm gonna
run it through my
machine with the people
that have been with
me for 15 years,
cause we give a shit about them.
And then we're gonna
build the fuck out of it,
flip it, buy the
New York Jets, win Super Bowls.
(audience laughing)
- So do you, do you
see yourself, then,
in keeping VaynerMedia,
like, as it is?
You know when you buy the Jets,
is VaynerMedia still
gonna be around?
- That's something I didn't see,
which I hate talking about.
I thought,
I thought I would build,
like, a hundred person
shop, it'd be great.
We'd buy a brand, you know,
I'd take 40 people over to it.
I would help the
other 60 get jobs
or put 'em in my other
investments.
Like, really take
care of the crew
and move on my merry way.
What ended up happening
is, look, we've gone
from 30 to 750 people in
four years, five years.
Like, there's gonna
be a lot more people
than I anticipated when
the brand comes.
So now I've, you know,
I've written a bunch of books.
I've started writing one called:
The By Accident
Billion-Dollar Company.
And it's really
the chronicles of
building Vayner
and why I did it,
and what happened,
and why did I,
why was I able
to build a big, big,
big business really fast?
Because our interests are
aligned with our client.
Like it's,
like it's just, you know,
it's always things,
it's always at
the tippy top, right?
Like everything that's broken
at VaynerMedia, my fault.
Everything is about the top, so
now I realize,
oh shit, I'm gonna
have a holding
company of brands,
but in parallel I'm also
gonna have VaynerMedia.
I'm going to take the
top talent, each year,
and graduate them into
the brands that I own,
but two interesting
things are gonna happen.
One, I think I'm
gonna be able to get
the best talent in
the world into Vayner.
Because, if the
word on the street is
if you go work at
Vayner, and you crush it,
that you can then go and
work on Hershey's Kisses,
or Keds and get
a piece of the action
and make lots and lots of money.
That's gonna bring
unbelievable talent.
And two, when I go
pitch for new business
at VaynerMedia,
instead of saying,
like, here's our sizzle
reel, or our capes.
I'm gonna be like, hey, four and
a half years ago
we bought Snickers.
It was doing
$237 million in revenue.
Now it's doing $8.7 billion
because of what we did.
That's our pitch, motherfucker.
(audience laughter)
- Well so, so yeah,
I mean convincing
someone to work at Vayner,
I don't think
should be too hard then.
- I don't think so.
I think, like, look,
I mean, like, everybody here
knows that that works,
and it, like,
and they, and they respect
it, and I respect it.
I'm not mad at
a holding company.
They're not, you know,
what are they,
like, this is not
non-profit world.
It's just, you have
to be smart about
why things do what they
do, and I think that
I'm excited to create a new
model in this ecosystem.
Because one thing
I have done, is fallen
in love with the DNA of
the people within it.
These are storytellers,
these are salespeople,
like, these are my, this is cool
this is what I am.
I didn't realize it, but, like,
this is what I am, too.
Little bit different
version of it,
but, pretty much,
what I am, and so
I think the machines
that have been
put in place aren't
great for the people.
And I think that, it's, I'm not
gonna be able
to employ everybody.
What I'm gonna do is be
ridiculously successful
and inspire Sally to
go and build it, too,
and create new alternatives.
- Well, we have
about five minutes left
so I wanted to open it
up to audience Q and A
if that okay with you.
- Yeah, let's do it.
(scoffing)
I prefer it.
- Let's do it,
firing any questions, anyone,
anyone here?
- Questions?
Awesome.
- [Woman] You said you
don't incentivize people
for new business, how do
you go about new business?
Do you find that
people are coming
to you because they know you?
Do you get involved in pitches,
how do you go about growing?
- Both of those things,
and then the other thing
that I didn't know, 'cause
I wasn't from the industry,
is when you do really good
work and people believe in you,
and they go move to other
companies, you get them, right?
So a lot of it comes from
my personal brand equity,
like I'm not building the
GaryVee shit for just my ego.
And so we get that,
but at this point we're
at such massive scale,
whether it's
the GE work, or Pepsi
work or the Toyota work.
We're out, we're doing
a lot of business.
And a lot of people are
moving and we're just winning.
Word of mouth, again, I'm
telling you, as cool as I am,
I go to the sales meeting
and I'm a great salesman,
the only thing that matters
is the steak, not the sizzle.
The sizzle's the gateway
drug to the steak.
And that's why we're growing.
- [Man] Can you tell
us what percentage of--
- What percentage
of what, my friend?
Of incentive compensation?
Like, if we grow this business
they'll kick us back dollars?
- Exactly.
- Zero.
And by the way, I'd love
to do all of it that way.
The problem is,
these CFOs and procure men
in corporate America
think I'm an idiot.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Like the incentive
plans are ludicrous.
And, by the way, I would
take it, but we're not big
enough yet, or real enough
yet for corporate America,
for them to really let
me control everything.
I'm not gonna be at the
mercy of, like, Digitas'
media plan, you know,
I have to run--
and that's not a dig at
Digitas, first thing to come...
(audience laughs)
It's just, if I'm gonna be,
I'm on the line,
I need to control everything,
then it's real, right?
So, zero so far though
it's kinda weirdly what
I thought I was gonna do,
you know? Stinks.
But I think I'm gonna play
the ultimate version of that.
When I write a check
for $88 million to buy
Pop rockets,
that's the ultimate putting
your money where your mouth is.
And that's what I came from,
that's what I'm actually
way more comfortable with.
All this politicking
horseshit, nah.
(audience chuckles)
- [Woman 2] Hi, I'm behind the
pillar, I'll step forward.
- That's awesome, how are you?
- [Woman 2] Hi, since you said
you wanna serve the people
in this room, they just heard
about a half an hour ago that
they're the most depressed
people in the agency.
- I'm sorry?
- [Woman 2] They just heard
they're the most
depressed group of people--
- Who, these people?
- [Woman 2] Mhmmm,
in the agency world
because they're strategists.
- Oh, okay.
- [Woman 2] What do you say to
them, I mean, what's you know,
what do you say to help?
- You know, one thing that
I've really enjoyed about
me getting more comfortable
in my own skin is,
I like saying I don't
know, more that I used to.
I'm not sure how
to fully answer that.
I'll tell you, I'm a
weird guy to ask that,
I don't know how
this is gonna come off,
but I was really against
having a strategy department,
because I was like why would
I hire people to just be
account, and just be management.
I need people to think,
what you guys know,
what I've learned is, not
everybody can do both.
I've come to learn that.
I don't know why they're
the most depressed.
From what I've learned,
and this is great,
I think you guys
might enjoy this,
because this is really
coming from left field,
and I don't have a lot of
good data on this other than
my own experiences.
I think you guys are being held
on a pedestal
in most places, right?
Like when I look at a
lot of places that I've--
I'm so surprised
that nobody talks
until the strategist talks,
or things of that nature.
I also think maybe, I saw
the lovely lady with the
camoflauge, shake her hand.
I was like, okay, then maybe
she means, to me it's crazy
that in a creative shop, the
creative is the most powerful.
In a world where this is all
subjective until
it hits the market.
So I don't know the
context of why the market
would think strategists
are the most depressed.
Is it because strategists
are similar to CMO's
which is, they have say
but not the ultimate say?
And people fuck up their
thoughts in execution?
I'm not sure.
(audience laughs)
Maybe.
But here's what I'm gonna say.
But then creative's are
going to talk about how
the media plan fucked them up.
Everybody's fucking crying.
Every discipline is crying.
If this was a fucking
creative, they would say that.
Everybody's crying, I think
people need to stop crying.
I think people need
to start understanding
how much of this is subjective.
By the way, the agency,
big brand world,
everything happens up front.
All the fighting, and the
jockeying, and the work,
and the debating, all this
shit happens up front.
Guys, we live in 2017,
this all needs to happen
after it hits the market.
This whole thing is so fucked
up, it's built for television.
It's not 1986.
Sorry.
Go read what happened in the
mid-50s, early 60s,
on the transition
of radio to television.
That's what
we're living through.
And then you will start making
very different decisions
in your career and probably
in your strategy meetings.
- We probably have
time for one more.
- Yeah let's do it.
- [Woman 3] Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- [Woman 3] Good, thank you.
- Great.
- [Woman 3] I'm an immigrant too
and I totally support
your ambitions.
- Thank you.
- [Woman 3] And I believe
you'll buy the Jets one day.
- Thank you, darling.
I love you.
- [Woman 3] And I'll be
the one cheering you on.
- Thank you.
- [Woman 3] I'm just curious
how you see America has changed
for you to execute
those ambitions
from when you were
a child 'til now.
- That's a great question.
I think not a whole lot.
I mean that.
I think what immigrants,
especially Soviet immigrants
that truly come from Communism,
understand is there's certain
things that are worse,
there's certain things
that are better.
It's evolved, but I always
deal in alternatives.
Here's what I know.
In the last 8 years, 12 years,
actually last 12 years,
I've had friends on
both sides of the aisle,
who told me if this person wins,
they're moving to Canada.
If Bush gets re-elected,
I'm moving to Canada.
If Obama gets re-elected,
So far, nobody's fucking
moved to Canada.
(audience laughs)
For me to ever think for
a pure-bred entrepreneur
to ever think the President
of the United States
has any impact on her or his
ability to execute in this game
they're a fucking loser.
So I don't think
it's changed at all.
I think there's a lot
of different dynamics.
And I think if you
really, really, really
want to look at
it at a macro level,
you know what
I'm most thankful for?
That even for all
the horse shit we have
around gender, and minority,
or things of that nature,
my daughter is in a
better position to execute
than she would have
been if she was my age.
It gets better,
I don't give a fuck what
the world tries to tell
you of how bad it is,
because that's what
drives Nielson ratings
on mainstream media,
it's fucking good.
It's good.
The problem is,
we're sold the 1%
that's bad every
single day, 24/7/365.
So I think it's great.
Super opportunity.
- I think that's a
perfect note to end on.
On an opportunity point.
(audience applause)
- Thank you.
Thank you.